can you can you wipe out that much red
Dre coughs daughter saw Paula the
hospital fire hoe Barton told me
everything you will ledger he's dripping
it's gushing red and you think saving a
man no more virtuous and yourself will
change anything this is the basis
sentimentality this is this is a child a
prayer opeth etic you lying killing the
service of liars and killers you pretend
to be separate to have your own code
something that will make up for the
Horus well they're a part of you a name
will never go away I went touch button
no not until I make him kill you slowly
intimately in every way he knows you
fear and then he'll wake up you wake up
just long enough to see his good work
and when he screams I'll split a skull
this is my bargain you mewling quim your
monster Oh No you brought the monster